with regard to cross-validation and
exploiting the scientific method why
don't we get to that quickly and then
we'll wrap up for today okay so you said
that in one of your talks we can use
cross-validation to exploit the
scientific method first what is
cross-validation you have to explain
that to the audience and then how does
it undermine science yeah um it's
actually i'm not sure what the exact
quote was but basically cross-validation
is the scientific method formalized
so
one aspect of the form of the scientific
method like so many um glib phrases it's
glob and leaves a lot out um
the scientific method we
don't we put far more
[Music]
um posterior probability we assign far
more credence
in a theory
if it predicts phenomena that we have
not already observed and then are found
to be true
so you know famously for example the um
who was it was eddington and um einstein
the observation of during the eclipse
and so on so forth
um
so another way to say that is that if i
give you two theories a and b
and i asked both of them to make a
prediction about something that neither
of them hasn't yet seen um an a predicts
it accurately and b does not then we say
let's go with a on making any subsequent
predictions
i'm going over and above
and so that it can be viewed as part of
the scientific method
now let's see what that might mean in
the context of machine learning
well if i want to choose among a bunch
of machine learning algorithms
one way to do it is to give them all a
bunch of data
and hold out some data
let them train on the data they have and
then just see which one does best on the
data it doesn't have
and this is actually done in contests
bake they're sometimes called all the
time
you know we're going to choose between
the following character recognition
algorithms by giving them all of this
data set holding out some other examples
and then seeing who does best
um
you can also though do that yourself
so to speak by say i've got myself i've
got a bunch of different algorithms that
i can use i've got a fixed data set
let me
play like i'm holding a bake off
train all these algorithms a part of my
data set
on part of my day is it see which one
does best on my held out data
take that one now train on everything
and use it to make my subsequent
predictions and use that as to choose
among different algorithms
just me myself as a solo machine learner
or to set parameters of a single
algorithm
that what i've just described to you is
what's called cross-validation
it is
it is part and parcel of machine
learning algorithms it is part and
parcel of the scientific method
it does not get around the no free lunch
theorems
that in point of fact
you can actually show and this is some
really strange stuff that will that i
would be very happy to talk about but it
will require some care in the discussion
that
the
algorithm of
of anti-cross validation
of choosing the scientific theory that
does worst at predicting
there are just as many priors
for which that is going to outperform
the scientific method as the other way
around
so very strange it almost makes no sense
when i just say it that way
so what would be an example of a
statement that we believe is
scientifically true but you believe it
was founded by inadvertently exploiting
something everything in science
whenever i cross the street everything
this is what i meant by why the the
norfolk lunch theorem is sometimes
just my notes to myself tp
everything
um the anti-reasoning by no free lunch
anti-reasoning rather than reasoning in
terms of inductive reasoning let me
state what cross-validation is one more
time simply to the audience so that some
of the people who weren't able to follow
can follow cross validation if you've
heard on a previous podcast i believe i
talked about kriptenstein there's a rule
following paradox so it's similar to
this imagine you have a kid a child
you're teaching how do you add digits so
you have a set of a thousand cards and
each of them is an arithmetical an
arithmetic statement a statement about
arithmetic so two plus five is seven
three to the power of four is is
eighty-one and then you show the child
the set of statements that are correct
you show them the set of statements that
are incorrect so some of these are true
plus 5 equals minus 1.
and then you say
and then you want to find out is the
child following a rule but the child
could have simply if you give them the
whole deck the child could simply
memorize all of these cards and you can
show them a card two plus three equals
five and you can say is this correct and
they'll be like that's correct and then
you don't know are they following the
rules of arithmetic or have they simply
fit the data so one way you can get
around that is you take let's say 70 of
your cards and you say learn some rule
child i'm not even going to tell you
what the rule is that's the point i want
you to learn figure out how to add by
looking at these examples and i'm saving
30 of these here so i can show you new
cards and say
is this one correct or incorrect and
then judging by that i can say whether
or not you're following the rules
correctly okay so that's what
cross-validation is now how does that
undermine science so that's essentially
the scientific enterprises you've
outlined it and how
so how does the no free lunch theorem
relate to that say it one more time
please
um
[Music]
it sounds like what you're saying is
well i could come up like the child can
come up with any rule and it would still
be
i could still find some situations in
which that rule is valid
just as many and in fact you could have
whatever the child
says you could i could define a new
algorithm
which is take whatever the child says
and go with the opposite so to speak
and there are going to be as many priors
as many universes we're talking about
the scientific method
in which that anti algorithm
is actually going to
end up doing best on yet unseen
situations
rather than the original one
and it's becomes very very
pointed when
it's things like um
[Music]
it means that for example there are
going to be as many situations in which
your algorithm does worse than random
guessing as in which it does better
no matter what your algorithm is
now this implies to me that scientific
method should not work yet it seems to
so why the problem yep the problem tp
because your very statement it seems to
is based upon the data set that has
worked so far
but then when we go to off drink the no
free lunch says doesn't mean the fact
that it's worked so far well in the past
has anything to say about how we'll work
in the future
it's just like evolution has worked so
well in the past has no implications
about how well it will work in the
future
so
it eats its own tail
it's not that anything that that we have
used go up to a meta level a meta
algorithm of some sort
where i'm choosing between strategies
for choosing between strategies doesn't
matter
um in fact there's a um philosopher
carl schers
who um just came out with a book on meta
induction it's making a big
um splash or waves you know whatever the
um serious aquatic metaphor of choice
and um he's got a whole chapter on no
free lunch and i actually just wrote a
commentary
um on that there were some that were
solicited and it's going to be appearing
in um
the journal of general philosophy of
science or something like that i forget
a precise name
where he claims that his results um get
around no free lunch but no they don't
um he's talking about meta induction at
this level so you're doing induction
about induction about induction
to try to essentially um break the
guardian
you know break free your binders but
they don't break free the binders you're
still stuck and we have no reason to
believe the scientific method but i sure
as hell believe it listen to the earlier
part of this podcast when i was
going whole hog i was the most died in
the wool
um conservative dogmatic scientific
reasoner you could come up with and then
the next breath i'll tell you that it's
got no legitimacy
by the way would you consider math to be
scientific or do you consider science to
be separate from math
oh um this is like you asked me before
about being an artist versus and so on
and so forth um i don't um
i don't make those kinds of distinctions
i will
yeah the reason i was asking is if you
did
consider it then it would be as if what
you're saying is by using science i've
undermined science
that is by using that which is subset of
which which is subset of science girdle
by using math undermined math
yup
well girdle undermined a part of math
whereas you're undermining the entire
scientific enterprise
yep pushing it further pushing it
further and then things like the
inference devices work
go even further they um in some senses
undermine the notion of um
epistemology full stop
of even knowing something no matter how
that information is arrived at even by
luck
and this gets to another very very much
tongue-in-cheek definition of free will
which was very very much tongue-in-cheek
um
and then the stuff on noise deductive
reasoning would say that oh but if math
itself including that reasoning that
you're using to come to these other
theorems is itself a noisy process
inherently
it's it's not it's not turtles all the
way down it's some uh straw men all the
way down or something like that